[Music]
the prime minister of the united kingdom
boris
johnson
has resigned man
wow is that good yeah well there's a lot
of corruption depends on who you are
that's usually a bad thing most people
don't willingly resign they want to
finish up their term or they go down
fighting yeah
some people say you know what it was
stolen what was stolen the election was
stolen some people say that they're like
no i should have won the uk election to
the uk every every president you know
that's out there they just go they just
everyone is the only one who said it was
stolen hillary never said anything with
stolen ever yeah that's true she
wouldn't [ __ ] know dude she never
said that russia tried to help anything
or nothing
technically it is bad i don't think
there should be any uh major main leader
of any organization and or country that
steps out or resides before their
predetermined time of uh that they
should be stepping down yeah because it
doesn't look good right it's a bad look
you know something spicy happened but he
had bad hair too so maybe his hair was
always a mess he never combed his hair
but this [ __ ] was like
[ __ ] putting out covet regulation
rules and like lockdowns and then it was
like hey it's my 56th birthday party i'm
gonna go party instead you gotta live it
up though it got caught people don't
care about that like his hair was like
has stringers like going on
bananas that's the big step but our
takeaway our deer leader newsom did that
and he got reelected but he's got great
hair but this is america
yeah i don't like i'm not a fan of gavin
newsom but he's got great hair i know
goose you know what newsome said that
actually related to me he said you know
what
i'm not perfect and i was like holy holy
[ __ ] this guy's a man of the people
where was this from our other leader i
was like here i was thinking he's a
piece of [ __ ]
and then he's like you know what i'm not
perfect i was like you're right that
elevates this [ __ ] way up here
actually because i was like oh i was
thinking you like a real piece of [ __ ]
like swirling around the toilet and now
i'm like oh he's not even he's like not
perfect oh that's way up here actually
and that's what saved him perfect yeah
so that's why i voted for him what's
that sign goes multiple times with
multiple i'm not perfect
what's that song i'm a dick oh you know
what it is
you don't know you just want to know
what actually is crazy about california
what they sent me like multiple ballots
i'm not kidding they sent me a mailing
in vegas i don't know in california oh
they sent me like mainland i just got
one ballot oh i got multiple ballots i
got four that's some white people [ __ ]
i think so i get extra votes dude you
get to vote for more people it must be
nice like hey you're your name you have
you have a middle name so we're sending
you one for that
[Laughter]
so no it was weird i was like whoa i got
four ballots what the [ __ ] am i going to
do so that so that's what you do i voted
for for uh gavin newsom with all four
times obviously four [ __ ] times that
was pretty cool or whatever i committed
a federal offense is what i did it is
pretty crazy that everyone hated his ass
wanted to recall his ass
and then like if you ever go to
sacramento like there's [ __ ] signs
surrounding the capitol pretty much
saying [ __ ] gavin newsom at his own
workplace
and somehow he got reelected
that's crazy because people like me
voting for him so many times they
couldn't even handle well he said he
wasn't perfect i was like he's not
perfect that's so relatable yeah yeah
he's a man of people yeah legit
so no um
there's so much corruption swirling
around boris johnson in fact this has
been going on for years uh joe has a
nice little inn oh yeah he knows a woman
from the uk
maybe give us a little insight on this
particular topic well the lowdown is his
own party told him
to resign
and he refused wait his own party said
what resign oh really and he says
how come they his own party you want him
to remember now
there is some infighting going on okay
and he says ner
and he says he's not going to resign
but rumors are he went to the queen and
the queen says resigned and he goes okay
and then queen told him to get the yeah
we have the power but the [ __ ]
queen's only do anything i'd do it i
wouldn't do [ __ ] i'll do everything
we're raising on different principles if
the queen tells you to do something
you're like [ __ ] you
queen says resign if prince andrew told
me to resign your boy's resigning i'm
resigned too
bro i think team harry for me really
yeah even though i don't think he's a
part of the royal family do you really
trust a redhead though because i have a
couple of nephews and nieces who am i
with dude oh oh yeah you're biased i'm
with the wendy's girl come on
straight up red i have nieces and
nephews who are redheads and i just
don't even [ __ ] trust them or
something shifty eyes or send them gifts
hey boris didn't this whole like uh
obviously for like three plus years
since like the old brexit [ __ ] and you
know what i mean that like got him like
his notoriety and his fame and popular
opinion with maybe half the country and
all that stuff
and then all the lockdown blah blah
sentiment but didn't the real um
catalyst of his resignation start from
like one of his [ __ ] cabinet members
who who had just been called out for uh
maybe going to a bar and like touching
men or something like that groping man
that was part of it and then he still
knew and he's still like promoting
that's what it is yeah yeah like he had
been told or like been given formal
complaints or something like that about
like this person then he appointed him
to that cabinet position regardless of
that even hearing it then denied once
the allegations came out on this most
recent incident that happened really
recently he had the guys back yeah he
like had the guys back then got called
out on being told about then he's like
ah [ __ ] my bad you caught me i did know
about this and that's like kind of why
a lot of the uh domino effect that's
going on right now really started with
that guy right yeah i thought he got
caught smoking crack too what what's
worse smoking cracker groping
he was like smoking a crack pipe and he
was like
oh dear this is so fantastic
well then he saw the uk stock market
he's like that's not jolly good
i thought after he smoked the crack he
was like oh yeah
snap me into this little heavens dear
what are we going to do
post crack clarity
do you talk to hannah about like uk
politics right now yeah all the time
it's interesting what's her life
what's her
personal perspective
personal perspective yeah like is she
like [ __ ] yeah get that [ __ ]
boris out or she like
she's like i miss theresa may
well i yeah i don't know because we both
are pretty anti-establishment in a way
we're like we know so we watch politics
as a big [ __ ] joke because no one's
being honest and we're trying to dissect
the plays that that we're doing so she's
not for or but personally we still have
our takes right like when like when they
shut down travel
the personal is like man [ __ ] that so
like what's her i guess what he's trying
to say is what's her personal take on
what's happening over there with my boy
which one she's choosing like what's the
what's the direction i haven't heard who
she supported but
she's she basically has theories on his
motives so for example right um brexit
and all these other things so one of the
things that she told me is that uh her
theory on boris and what he's doing is
yeah his career is over like it's been
over because all the scandals and all
the things like he's probably not gonna
get re-elected she's thinking that he's
trying to do as many trade deals and
things with the u.s because he's
actually u.s born
and what brexit all these things they
they benefit u.s suddenly you love him
he sounds like a beetle what about
doesn't make any sense he's a brit right
and i mean he i think he grew up in the
uk but he was born in the us and stuff
like where yeah i think it's new york or
something
they're allowed to do that yeah ours
can't do that like you're present you
have to be born here
what happened to madonna though they're
really diverse out there like she told
me that they have like you know uh
indian uh members in politics just like
it's just very diverse and like american
or foreign-born people in politics just
not the president right it's not the
president yeah but i think that's a
small top indian rule yeah yeah yeah
kamala's have i mean she's she's not
black is the only thing
oh you know what no no it's not just
multicultural but like so in u.s it's so
christian right that it's new to have a
muslim politician like that's a new
thing
to have a new like you know like in in
congress or whatever right but out there
they've been having muslim mares and
things like that for a long [ __ ] time
so they're way more diverse they're way
more multicultural and things like that
but the boris take and i think this is
super interesting is that um
the reason for brexit all these things
was to loosen up trade deals that they
have with the us because all the eu
rules was preventing them from importing
exporting stuff together and doing
business so during covid you know how
there was a specific [ __ ] rule where
like people from uk can't come here and
then we can't go there and it was just
the most ridiculous [ __ ] law like
europeans could do it why the [ __ ] can't
people from uk come right it's not for
covid but it might have been a
a trade strategy to restrain the like
economics of like the airlines or
whatever they needed to do to hash out a
deal and be like we'll free it up but
like we need to [ __ ] get this signed
first right so behind the scenes we're
thinking it could be pharmaceutical
because they're trying to um
do some [ __ ] with the nh whatever s or
whatever which is like a medical their
their free health care thing right they
wanted to buy [ __ ] medicine from the
u.s uh uh they wanted to start buying us
beef uh they wanted to
clear up a lot of
like food regulations that u.s can start
selling out there so that's her take on
it is he's trying to create a sweet ass
deal so when he exits office then he's
going to have a lot of money in the
private sector
yeah people say that kamala harris is is
you know indian
right and she was also
from african american descent like from
jamaica
but that's like the controversy that
some people say is like they're like oh
well she's not black because she's half
indian
that's like saying obama's not black
because he's half white
yeah that's so sweet that's like saying
why do people look at tiger woods and
think he's mainly black when he's more
asian than he's black yeah no he can't
be black dude no well he's not black
because he got drafted by the whites
he's already he's already white dude
yeah that's a confirmed historical
moment